oh my God no no oh my God oh my God no
God oh no did it keep any of the stuff
no we lose it all and the stuff in the
ship too yep it's all going oh but I was
right there so what happens that we
didn't make quota probably well I guess
we'll find out we need what 230
something mhm oh oh well what's going to
happen as you have not
oh God the
company
oh how
long how guys oh
oh
oh oh oh hey ah first day on the job
feels good death man I I am eager for
this guys I I hear good things about
this job I heard there was some kind of
song they make you sing I'm really not
into that I love the company how about
you I love the company I don't I don't
really
I'm song I don't want look I'm I'm a
professional I'm here to do a job and
I'm here to do it well that's why I've
gotten to this point that's why I've
reached this status and um I'm not going
to let anyone dance their way into some
disciplinary action I'm here for the as
the Navigator I've sent us to our first
assignment there thank you finally some
professionalism okay uh Captain Mark do
you want to pull the lever technically
oh sure sure sure yeah absolutely yeah
yeah well I mean I just want you to know
that like the captain C is really not
it's it's not military so it's not a
rank that you need to respect but
salutes would be nice thank you well all
right he's gone let's get out of
here w a door but hey what's up ah hey
what's upy company this guy compy
dancing like an aole yeah all right
let's get to it guys remember midnight
we're out of here whether we're on the
ship or not that ship's
gone we're going to spend that many
hours here yeah and look we're looking
for anything valuable I don't care if
it's t Kettle I don't care if it's a
baking dish we grab it we
go is he all right yeah oh if he's not
on the ship he's not on the ship what
are you going do he's not on the ship if
he wants to dance his day away fine
whatever all right you got right I'll go
left right door's locked I'm going
straight ahead all right man if only we
had like a stash of key ooh engine I
know all right you in
here uh no but I hear you
okay looks like we got a land mine at
the end of the hall
[Music]
what oh [__] blob hey guys oh hey hey I
got you're not dead I thought you were
dead no oh wa my God hello hey what
happened to you watch out for the blob I
used the fire exit oh okay well that's
interesting this was a dead end until we
go this direction I gu TR the
be oh man I've lost
you whoa oh that waste
[Music]
time
okay that's all
right we've done
worse what the hell help help guys help
me guys there's something on my head
there's something on my head captain
there's something on my
head oh uh there's something on my
head follow the sound of my voice what
do you mean follow the sound of your
voice get it off my head oh God there's
a goo over here
oh oh bom don't go any oh no no no no no
no no
Bob you good I'm good I'm good oh no I'm
not good run
[Music]
Bob
B got my master's degree of doing
things oh my God he's alive
okay well Fire EX I guess is the way to
go and I'm sure that other idiot will be
out here too I'm sure I'm not alone hey
Bob hey what talking about you I thought
you were dead for a while no I'm good I
just decided to the face hugger thing
was sort of guarding the door and I was
like I'll just I'm I'll just carry stuff
back to the ship for now that's fine
that's a good idea we need a shovel to
save people from that or a stop sign or
a yield sign I had a fever dream where
we had a shovel at one point but now we
don't the other thing you can do I was
trying to guide Mark if you get to an
exit door that's on your head and you
exit it dies but as soon as you get
through the door for some reason oh that
sounds like a bug it's not logical but
it happens um do we leave we can um do
you think we're already almost to our qu
we could just leave and go get I can go
try to get him he's right by I can't
tell where he is do you want to try and
get him or do you want to try get him I
think he's by the fire exit yeah just
keep an eye on me if I die go ahead and
leave
yep oh there's buttons on the side he
maybe Captain's just taking a nap I'm
sure any moment now he'll snap back to
Consciousness remember he'll He he'll
regain his widths and he'll um he'll be
ready to to
rumble this guy's definitely going to
try die trying to get his body back
though oh he's got it he's found
it no red dots wow look at that if I was
like a 10B man just what you just found
him man weighs 11 lb that's it well he's
dead so it's the soul is like 95% body
oh that's true his soul is up there with
Hitler and Jesus now hey look Bob look
his screw is
loose
uh you know what you're you're winning
me over new guy yeah it's too much
dancing laest employee the most paranoid
and the most profitable I feel like
that's our that's our
[Music]
captain Oh
man hey did when of you guys get the
thing it was on my head thanks for that
no we just ran away and it left it it
was probably you probably you Bob not
this guy this lazy sack of [__] yeah no
he he didn't do anything I definitely I
definitely save you C oh man thank you
hey Hey listen listen
listen when there's uh when we go meet
the boss uh there's going to be a big
promotion in store for you store for you
just you gucci gucci gucci
goo hey uh why don't you get to work
we're going to
experimentation also I love that there's
button on the side for the monitor I was
going I went to the the console type
switch and then your name every time you
don't have to type the name you just
type switch oh wow but also there's a
button here yeah the button's good
unless you're trying to quickly go
between people when you're on there um
you don't also if you do want to go to a
specific person type switch then the
first three letters of their name you
don't type the whole name out ah that
that it help that's
helpful what
wait wait what what what what what what
wait what did what what did you where
where did the Shelf go problem wait what
do you mean what do you mean what do you
mean what what do you mean what do you
mean I mean what do you why are you
acting like that what do you mean wait
we there was a shelf here and now it's
not this is not how reality Works what
do you mean there was never a shelf
there there was there was a shelf there
there was a shelf there there was a
filing cabinet a double filing
cabinet so uh which way do we go captain
uh well so if um I see those two lights
in the distance that probably is it so
oh right that's the thing uh I did order
more walkies so we going have
walkies I don't see the
light Captain with yeah Captain went the
wrong way Captain was scouting the
surroundings making sure it was safe
looking up on The High Ground where the
hell are you guys sorry Captain had to
look at the low grounds too
guys
guys you
um
guys
[Music]
C
okay I'm getting out of
here what in the [__] was
[Music]
that oh my
God oh my God what was
that
[Music]
hey bud oh there you are how did you
guys disappear where did you go where's
the the the main entrance is straight
ahead so we ran that way You' already
gone but no there was a no I I went you
the thing landed and you said Captain is
here and then I went the wrong way and
then I went back up to the thing and it
had already gone you guys were gone yeah
we grabed walking went to the main
entrance thinking that we you there I
saw was like that way right anyway I
found a I found a back fire entrance uh
that has so much stuff what does he
need what do you need I just was
wondering if you were alive sir oh yeah
of course I'm alive I'm the captain
going stra oh Bob here take a left after
jump
AC okay now you can make that try to
make the jump but be careful take your
time
wow he's an expert he is a
pro that he is all let's go to your exit
and get your stuff I saw there was a
bunch of stuff there which exit man or
fire one that you the one that you used
the side one over on the side here yeah
whichever fire exit you use there's
there's three fire exes on this map that
I know of yeah I went on the one behind
here I don't think that's the one you
guys were using um no no it's not which
is why I want you to lead me there oh to
mine yeah oh I I basically cleared
everything that on there were two more
items on the map near you I couldn't
tell
you see I see I'll I'll tell you where
they're at I'll go back and tell you
where they're at okay sounds
good all
right all right I'm inside there's item
to your right immediately back back oh
you're right Big Bolt right there yeah
all right what
else uh keep going this
way the map has to kind of oh there's an
enemy mark where
[Music]
where I'm I'm I'm getting out I'm
getting out of
here stop that uh Captain I think I'm
going to take blame for something I
didn't do sir and what was that I was
trying to guide you I was giving you
guidance was the malfunction on someone
else's ah I see I'll listen to him
captain he's a
liar listen hey stop fiddling with your
radio he's stilling that Captain listen
there's going to need to be some
discipliner I'm not even holding a radio
do I risk going to the fire ex that I
usually use or do we just take the win
what what's in there I like there's
nothing wrong with taking a win on this
one let's take this sweet du what wait
what time is it it's like never mind
yeah let's yeah yeah I took a look
around the corner and I didn't like what
I saw so I'm outside Captain I don't
know there was something glowing and I
didn't like
it
hello if I'm out here and we leave
atmosphere is that bad yeah probably
probably not good oh I was trying to go
back damn we are swimming in it boys
yeah we really can't uh we really can't
afford to all not make it back one of us
probably need to make it back every time
hey guys I lost my walkie is it on the
floor in here somewhere in your panicked
attempt to hide your crimes did you
throw it oh there it is no I I dropped
it cuz I was going to go outside for the
um for the for the when leaving the
atmosphere right right yeah you know
this is uh going swi swi well s slight
swimming well that's a lot of pumpkins
are the pumpkins the treeple do they
hatch or something oh we'll have to see
I don't that's a good question but I
feel like there's always
pumpkin there's a lot of pumpkin
where we go to the lights is that the
deal this is where the bridges are this
way yeah oh right this is a lot of
pumpkins it's a strange amount of
pumpkins this bridge is different I feel
like I feel like I didn't notice the
pumpkins
exist the entrance is on the fire exit's
down here I'm going to go to fire exit
where this is that's that's a secondary
Bridge oh okay yeah that was different
yeah don't drop down left of the Stone
Bridge that's that
okay I'm with you Captain all right
sounds good all right I'm leaving you
Captain all right
bye that's
dark oh I can't see that
hello yeah what's up the to the right
was the total dead end is this is this
you captain that I'm following
you
we got some stuff in here we also got
the big glowy thing big glowy power
core we got the power core here
Wade
Wade yeah yeah you got some power yeah
the big glowy yellow thing should we
take that usually that's the last thing
we take you can take it but if you take
it now it makes things get bad the whole
facility loses power or something which
also encourages the nasties to come out
and play all right it's fine because
it's right by the entrance it's actually
in a convenient location I've got two
twoed object fire carry
back okay I did not follow you to the
fire exit I've got a bug down I'm going
to I'm going to walk down and grab the
other one
then all
right Whoa We got some funky birds
flying
around oh
uh should I go grab just the big yellow
thing then maybe we just get out of here
that let's just get out of here and call
the all right Roger
that Wade you cut that [__] right now uh
malfunction
sir yeah right I'm about to malfunction
all over
you I say like that I don't think you
mean that yeah yeah the discipline's
going to be exceptionally harsh on your
ass Bob has volunteered to take my place
of
tribute you can torture me as much as I
want Captain oh yeah well in that case
Wade you're going to watch you're going
to watch as I discipline Bob in your
place sir yes
sir ah you can't talk now cuz he's
carrying heavy
stuff Captain is a big dude pants okay
all right well that's just
dumb Captain so dumb he's probably going
to fall off that bridge he's on yeah I
can't even walk a straight
line oh look out Captain there's
probably three
people oh that was
uh hope those pumpkins don't hatch
captain
it's okay you're definitely going to
make it
back oh God oh God oh God oh God step
step step step get G what are you doing
I was I was initially joking but it
really wasn't that much of a joke
Captain okay all right okay I I was here
rolling my eyes up into the back of my
skull doing somersaults in my head and
you you didn't tell me it was real it
wasn't
real until that last possible
second all right I thought it was a joke
the whole time I got to be honest well
we're doing great this is uh really good
I didn't get injured but okay hey this
is going really good we got a lot of
money here yeah yeah one of you want to
type in company and take us
in what do we love the company all right
the company cuz we are well I guess I
guess we can let him dance a little bit
he did he did admirably we love the
company love the we are the
company turn around when you dance you
know I used to rap in my
youth fing in the sky and flying on the
land getting some loot can you give me a
hand for the company for the company oh
I need a hand for the company Captain
can you make it stop yeah I used uh stop
please all right
freaking rich out
here so what do we do when we're rich
what happens we start wearing
monal okay all right I like monocles I
want to find myself a nice cabin on Val
and just settle down what about
you I don't know I was thinking of uh
yeah just seeing how far this can go
maybe uh just see the reaches and depths
of which uh the universe is there I'm
really here to explore
you guys are real Company Men
wow well we can't just dance our life
away that's for sure yeah you got to you
got to work hard that's how you show the
company your worth mhm you could do you
want to hear my company rap no
no didn't we
already oh well no that was just the
Prelude wait did that stuff sell I get
should probably not leave till that
happens huh oh there there go why is the
V type engine only worth five I don't
know they have items have random value
it changes I guess we got really unlucky
with that yeah all right well whatever
let's go onwards and
upwards damn look at that so we get to
we get to keep all that extra and apply
it to the next quoda right out of
fairness uh well what you can do is not
sell it all so we could have kept some
of it oh now why would we do that we
wouldn't be able to afford all the
incredible equipment that's going to
help us in the future right boys this
guy let me look at this have enough we
do have enough to buy
something whoa a zap a jetpack yeah we
could get jet packs we could get
something called a teleporter or an
inverse teleporter which seemed like
basically the same thing I'm going to
buy some uh flashlights and stuff first
and then we'll see what we have left to
play with okay so do the triangles on
the map are those items always Yow
triangles are items yeah and you can see
those on the map without scanning yeah
oh okay should we have someone stay in
the ship now and do this super
officially we could take turns I'll do
it you do we take turns yeah sure if you
guys want I go first we take turns hey
there's a button here now what is that
hey there a hey Captain is this new what
whoa I'm going to stand in it let's see
what it does all
right uh it doesn't seem to do anything
Captain there's a button push the button
all
right no not that button scary an
ominous that's for
sure oh oh wo wo wo wo wo huh well that
was cool all right
fireworks
okay wait a minute that's that's that's
incredibly useful is that what I think
it is W does that does that bring people
back back
[Music]
here whoever's not in the ship does it
just bring him back yes but you no
monitoring yeah if you look at the
ground where you guys were standing you
don't bring anything back with you so
it's an
emergency well better than dying righty
or a body recovery
yeah there's our
items
d d do I need to come grab anything I'll
come get it for you don't worry I got it
I'm bringing them
in okay well something's going on with
the radios
man why does this keep turning on when I
store it I don't like
that oh if it's if it's on and I store
it okay we got two shovels
flashlight all right radio's on Bob you
standing in the ship yes I stay in the
ship that's me ship boy okay sounds good
we're going
in also known as teleporter
man uh Bob type view space monitor on
the
terminal what' you say view on on the
terminal the thing you go to the store
and stuff on type view then a space then
monitor
why cuz then you can have the map up
there and if we need something you can
interact with it more
quickly oh
okay look if you want me to say it and
give you an official order would that
make you feel better yes hey buddy boo
hey why don't you go over to that uh
terminal over there it's the thing with
the keys the keyboard the board of keys
and why don't you type
uh oh I don't know why don't you type
view space monitor you know how to spell
that
got it
sir all right jamp all right jamp I'll
give oh my
God yeah we got bouncy head right right
at the front entrance holy crap oh
that's bad yeah um okay Wade you get out
of here is there a fire exit uh not sure
where but
yes
wa wait I got I got eyes on it go and
drop that outside and and let's go to
the fire exit
huh
um it's to the
right oh
oh it out there's a turret too can we
use that to kill this
thing I don't think you can kill these
but that's I canate teleports from the
terminal or do I have to hit the
button
button okay we don't need a Teleport
right now though we can get out yeah
Wade why don't you look around for
anything else here I'll keep an eye on
it and keep it right there so you get
out more doors there's a yellow there's
a
tur got it this this is a go left and
through that hallway and then to the
left in the next area there's a triangle
on the floor oh you just passed it he's
behind you behind you on the right wall
like behind you yeah like right
there this thing is
ugly is that you please tell me that's
you holy
[__] all right but I mean your left oh
it's a coil isn't it Mark we have a
second one all right can you rope it
into a place where I can watch
both
try is that the only way down through
that long hallway there to your left so
you can see down both okay I got both I
got both I got eyes on both I got both
I've got both right now but I think it's
closing off our exits land mine land
mine or Red Dot otherwise it is a land
mine and I think I see a blue there's a
land mine there
too is there any
loot there's a bug carrying loot ahead
of you there's also a land mine ahead of
you to the right and this sucks yeah
this is awful maybe we
bail this might be a bu this might be a
we need to get out cuz there's bad stuff
everywhere yeah oh third coil head just
showed up to the party but he's behind
with blob blob incoming we got we got a
countdown right now blob is incoming
towards the main entrance we got 10
seconds I think get out yeah go for
it oh my God I can't believe you got out
ah what we
got Mark there there's dogs around
careful
I don't see them on the
map Roger
that yeah I see
them they don't seem to be between the
path from us to the ship but who knows
how long that'll last I'm going try to
make my way
[Music]
there
hey
Captain screw you
man I was it go what screw me what I
helped I just said Hey where's
Wade okay there he is okay I'm going to
there's one more ax go show up on the
camera cuz I'm not seeing
them only for close enough to
them yeah they seem to be in a space
otherwise I'm going to
go where's the axle I don't see it my
flashlight chip to your
left no no no to your left Stop
sh okay it's it's so you're left 90° I
don't know if it's on the same
plane
they're coming to the ship oh my
God
what
[Music]
VI